[Music]
it all takes place in bolivia and since
2017 we have fixed more than 30 camera
traps on trees
at some point it became very difficult
to screen all the photos that's why we
came up with the idea to include
volunteers citizen science
[Music]
on one hand we have realized that this
area has hardly been studied but it is
very much endangered at the same time
deforestation takes place here at
breakneck speed trees have been removed
for cattle grazing we did not know much
about mammals so we started to hang up
camera traps
[Music]
do
[Music]
we like wildlife projects a lot because
we can learn so many new details like
lots of animals we didn't know about
it's also fun to identify the different
species and mark them and we can help
and support the scientists with their
work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and tapia i like the most
those are the most spectacular ones i
like to see how they live in bolivia's
drive forest and if you see that i think
you're likely against cutting down the
forest
[Music]
you